[Musique]
pour les amateurs de modélisme
ferroviaire nous réunions sur un monde
où les voisins sont toujours aimables
les amoureux finissent toujours ensemble
Alison les souvenirs que je chéris le
plus précieusement sont tous liés à toi
je t'aime je t'aime et le train vous
emmène toujours vers des contrées
lointaines que vous vous étiez promis de
visiter
[Musique]
bien sûr dans la vie rien n'est aussi
propre et ordonnée
ma fiancée en attendant
la femme qui est morte allait devenir ma
belle-sœur
[Musique]
je m'inquiète pour toi je veux retrouver
ma vie je veux retrouver ma fille
j'ai besoin que tu m'aides je sais
[Musique]
Alison ne fuyez pas maintenant à cause
de moi il y a des milliers de réunions
j'en trouverai une autre aussi
venez
il y a tellement de choses qui ont été
hors de contrôle ces derniers temps j'ai
surpris ma petite fille en train de
faire l'amour avec un garçon qui avait
l'air d'un homme Belinda j'ai surpris ce
minable au lit avec baraya elle a dit
qu'elle avait 18 ans sur les réseaux
c'est un sacboy c'est comme ça que les
jeunes les appels fiche le camp de ce
quartier
fort
qu'est-ce que tu as fait à tes cheveux
c'est pour bien commencer la semaine on
est vendredi
[Musique]
ma femme restait souvent ici avec moi et
les mecs SIFF
laient
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je sais pas comment faire c'est du
boulot j'ai pris un cellier audio la
bibliothèque comment parler aux ados
je vais clairement pas parler de ça avec
mon grand-père parce que j'adore parler
de ça avec toi je suis complètement
dépassé
je me disais que si on trouvait des
trucs sympas à confectionner on pourra
même passer dans l'émission pour les
investisseurs on dirait salut les
associés oh
je savais que cette idée de pleurer